this story about gamestop
and the gamestop stock price going
through the roof
this is the single funniest story that i
have seen
in years and not only is it hilarious in
and of itself
but it actually has deep political
implications
and the political implications are
simply delightful
i i fear that because this involves
finance and involves investing
this story might be a little too
complicated for most
people who aren't going to pay very
close attention to it to
understand just how funny it is so i'll
try to break it down
very simply because i don't know
anything about finance either but
i i've at least read a fair bit about
this
particular uh once in a century type of
event once in a lifetime type of event
a bunch of internet trolls on the
reddit board wall street bets decided
wall street bets this is like an
irreverent investing board
this is not like a sober serious
investing board they just put up kind of
crazy risky bet ideas
they noticed that hedge funds had taken
a short position
on gamestop gamestop is this video game
store right
you know what gamestop is it doesn't
have a ton of growth potential
it seems like it's kind of heading out
the door kind of like blockbuster some
of these old companies
so these internet trolls
discover that wall street took out a big
short position on this specifically one
hedge fund called melvin capital
and a short position is when basically
when you're betting against the stock
so if the stock price goes down you make
a lot of money and if the stock price
goes up not only do you lose money but
you've got to start buying it up so
you've got to start putting more cash on
the table
to cover your losses right so gamestop
though
it was trading at like six dollars not
that long ago it wasn't doing great
uh hedge funds take out huge short
positions on this
and these trolls at wall street bets
decide you know
we're gonna make this stock price on
this kind of crappy company
go through the roof and maybe we'll make
some money in the process
but more importantly we are just going
to mess with these hedge funds
these guys we have no sympathy for them
we're going to completely mess
with the financial establishment and the
craziest thing is
it's working the the board has i think
two million members
and so i was asking myself when this was
going on how why hasn't this been done
before
and the reason is you've never had this
kind of
the the technology to do it you know to
wrangle like two million of these kind
of eccentric type of people
but you've also never had the
memes you've never had the humor
you've never had the specific political
conditions
of people wanting to flip the bird to
the establishment
which they believe has r royally
screwed them over in in recent months
you've had
individual aspects of that kind of thing
but you've never had it all
coincide this whole phenomenon is
very internety okay so it's very
the kind of lingo that people use
they'll they'll be joking about how
you know they're just gonna grit their
teeth and take some of the losses
until their mom brings them chicken
tendees into the basement
you know and they they're using all this
kind of very internet lingo
they actually they have like sheet sea
shanties that are being posted
they posted one last night about how
we've got to uh we've just got to hold
on as the financial
industry pushes back because we're all
going to make a bunch of money in
bankrupt wall street
there once was a stock that put to see
the name of the stock was
gm me the price blew up and the shorts
dipped down
hold my bullet boyz hole soon may the
tendy man come
to send a rocket into the sun one day
when the training is done we'll take our
she had not been two weeks from shore
when ryan cohen
joined the board the captain called all
hands and swore he'd take his shares and
hole
soon may the tendy man
it goes on and on like this uh so far
gamestop
not a great company uh is up something
like
2500 this month the stock has hit
i think 460 dollars a share amc movies
this is another company that's basically
headed for bankruptcy right because no
one's going to the movies anymore
amc there they sent this one through the
roof they sent blackberry up you know
the old cell phone company
that's up 250 i think they were going to
target nokia as well another cell phone
company that nobody uses anymore
it's all just a huge meme
however the meme is becoming reality
so that the internet joke is totally
affecting reality and it's gonna put
hedge funds out of business
gabe plotkin who's the hedge fund uh
trader uh
at melvin capital uh he was the one with
the biggest short position
yesterday when this news broke he had to
raise almost three billion dollars
to bail out the fund squawk box which is
you know the very serious sort of
cnbc financial news show they just
couldn't make any sense of it you know
we've mentioned social media i couldn't
help but
it's not obviously similar to some of
this uh
controversy surrounding facebook and
twitter and everything else but but once
again what what's
one of the uh one of the things that
we're talking about is
maybe misinformation and and uh pump and
dumps and it's occurring on social media
again it just
i'm wondering whether it's part of the
same problem the type of regulation that
that
uh that we finally need to to consider
and like i said
we should always have a light touch with
regulation but
you're you're seeing the way things can
get started again this is different
maybe it's reddit maybe it's not
facebook but you're seeing
the the the same situation at this point
it's not about an election it's not
about a
an insurrection but there are
interesting things happening that that
seem to be spawned to some extent or at
least
at least blown out of proportion by
social media
again that entire monologue was
completely meaningless that guy has
absolutely no idea what he's talking
about first of all some of the things
he's saying are just
factually not true he's saying this
might be a pump and dump it's not a pump
and dump
a pump and dump is where you pick a
stock cynically
you bring up the price really really
high and then you try to find a bigger
idiot to sell it to
so you're going to totally mess that guy
over but you're going to make money at
his expense that's not what's going on
here what's going on here is
these internet trolls found a giant
short position from a giant
institutional investor
and they said nah i don't think so we're
not going to let you guys do that and so
then
this uh financial analyst on cnbc says
well i don't know maybe it's uh maybe we
need to regulate this
i mean we want a light touch on
regulation but we can we can't let these
guys do it what he's really saying is
we don't want any regulation for the
institutional investors
we don't want any regulation for wall
street when they do this exact thing
but we do want regulation for ordinary
people
we can't let individual investors do
this kind of thing then the whole game's
going to be up
what is going on here is not primarily a
financial phenomenon it's a political
phenomenon and it is
the same phenomenon that you've been
seeing build up coinciding
in part caused by in part causing the
trump
phenomenon it's ordinary people
rebelling against
an established elite that they don't
have any faith in
a lot of times this word populism gets
thrown around and i think it's
often sort of a silly word because i
don't think people are either populists
or
elitists for instance if we have a good
elite
then i'm an elitist if we can have a
good virtuous
smart thoughtful elite then great works
for me i
count me in the elitism category
but we don't have that we have a bunch
of corrupt
cynical idiots in our so-called elite
and so with that kind of an elite i'm
i'm the opposite of an elitist i'm the
furthest thing from i'm a total populist
if the elites that we are currently
governed by are hipster rasputin jack
dorsey a grown man with a with a nose
ring
and the crooks of the obama biden
liberal dominant regime
and the educational establishment which
is
utterly upending liberal education if
those are the elites
i'm out right and that's what you're
seeing here and you're seeing all these
unwashed peasants on these internet
boards eating their chicken tendies
you're seeing them outfox the wall
street elite
and they are not they are not liking
that very much so now the financial
establishment
is pushing back they're trying to shut
these guys down
you know in a way the media understands
this thing so so chris seliza at cnn
posted this piece yesterday that that
people made fun of but he actually had
sort of a point he said
how trumpism explains the gamestop stock
surge
and it is kind of a negative article but
if you take the
preference out of it you just look at
the phenomenon yes
it does sort of explain that but then
other
media outlets do the same thing they do
to all the trump people
they say well the only way to explain
what's going on right now is to say that
the people doing this have awful
terrible intentions and they're evil and
they're bigoted
and they're neo-nazis and they're white
supremacists and we got to shut the
whole thing down
they're the the elites are making the
exact same mistake
with regard to this kind of frivolous
financial phenomenon
that they have for the political
phenomenon and just like
trumpism it isn't going anywhere this is
only more evidence
that sure you can vanquish trump for now
but you're not getting rid of the forces
that propelled trump and that that have
supported him
mother jones the liberal outlet i guess
even further leftist outlet is
looking at the gamestop wall street bets
phenomenon
and following up on what the cnn types
are saying saying this isn't just
trumpism
this is neo-nazism this is white
supremacy one reporter from mother jones
says
i can report from the telegram channels
that the nazis
appear to be trading gamestop and amc as
well
now why why would someone say that why
would someone's
i i don't how do you know that's the
nazis trading this
how do we i mean to mother jones
everyone to the right of hillary clinton
is a nazi
i think the reason to say that is
because it justifies
shutting it all down if it's not if it's
ordinary internet trolls eating chicken
tenders
you don't have a good argument to shut
shut down trading on this stock
because ordinary people are doing what
institutional investors have done for a
long time
but if it's nazis you can do whatever
you want a reporter for the hill a much
more mainstream
outlet writes to the reporter from
mother jones what is your sense of the
overlap between the wall street bets
people and the nazis on telegram
and elsewhere who stormed the capital oh
good
maybe we can use the fbi to go to their
homes and and
shut them down and put them in prison
and take away all their money they can't
do this darn it
discord a social media platform shut
down the wall street
bets account for hate speech
for hate speech because they drove
gamestop
and amc and blackberry because they
drove them through the roof
to wreck some wall street investors for
the laws
for the laughs they booted them for hate
speech this is the same thing you you
see
done to conservatives whenever they walk
a little bit away from the liberal
establishment whenever they
question in any way the dominant liberal
regime
what are we told we're told that's hate
speech that's
bigotry it's dangerous it's a threat
uh you're a nazi or a white supremacist
and we've got to
we've got to censor you nasdaq
is considering halting trading to let
the investors quote recalibrate nasdaq
ceo idina friedman said
that the exchange could halt trading
activity for stocks
in the event that they were targeted by
these internet users
so you're going to let these giant
bigwigs on wall street
have a have a completely unfair
advantage
on investing when their stocks get when
their investments get threatened
but ordinary people what happens when
you're with
far less knowledge by the way what
happens when you lose some money in the
markets
do they do they stop trading on nasdaq
for you i don't think so
the white house for their measure are
monitoring the situation jan saki the
press secretary was asked about this
and she had a typically profound answer
is the way i was concerned about the
stock market activity we're seeing
around game stop
um and now with some other stocks as
well uh including
the the subsidiary or whatever the
company that was
a blockbuster um and have there been any
conversations with the
sec about uh how to proceed
well um i'm also happy to repeat that we
have the first female treasury secretary
and a team that's surrounding her and
often questions about market we'll send
to them hold on
what hey uh this is the strangest day in
the markets that we've had
in uh a hundred years uh what's going on
over there well i'd like to remind you
that the treasury secretary
has breasts
okay can you tell us anything about the
markets
she identifies as a woman and her
pronouns
are she and her yes uh yes jensaki i
understand all that but i need
things that matter i need information i
need information that matters
not just your ridiculous
liberal identity politics claptrap
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you